Let's go next to Harsh from Dallas.
You're on the air. What's on your mind?
Hello? Can you hear me? Yes, I can. He did nice
to talk to you. Likewise, I started following
your country recently, I'm fairly new to this
country as well. I just had a small question.
Sure. So you frequently talk about education
and media literacy for a lot of people in this
country. Yes. I was just wondering, how
would you hypothetically make these ideas
mainstream and how do you push these ideas
without sounding like a Nazi propaganda?
Sorry, you're saying that media talking about
media literacy could sound like Nazi propaganda.
Yeah, because of the education,
when you use the term education.
That sounds like what China is doing to Muslims.
Oh, I don't call it that. I mean, what I say is we
need to deal with the failings of the educational
system. We need to be teaching media literacy and
philosophy and critical thinking and epistemology
starting probably in sixth or seventh grade. But
no, you're right. I mean, I have to say that we
need reeducation camps or reeducation in the U.S.
The language of that would not play so
well, and I think that should be avoided.
OK, do you think that's going to
make it into a policy or something?
Well, you know, at the state level,
most education in the United States
is governed by state boards of education.
And there are states that do teach some of
all or all of these things. So, yeah, I think
I think it's a very achievable goal. You know,
does does the Texas State Board of Education
want to be teaching media literacy and critical
thinking to seventh graders? I don't know.
Judging by the decisions they make on textbooks,
it's not very clear to me. But I think
that this is a completely achievable goal.
OK, Harsh from Dallas, thank you very, very much
for the call. We are going to take a very quick
break. It's going to be very, very quick.
If you're holding, don't hang up, because
I'm going right back to the Dischord phone lines
momentarily. Quick break and back to the phones.